welcome to the the sixth in this uh
lecture series of understanding anger
this is the fourth of the philosophical
perspectives we did two
more
religious and poetic perspectives before
that and now we've been running through
you know the various ancient schools of
philosophy
this by contrast to the other ones we've
done is what we can call a non-socratic
school
and i'll talk about what that means
in a few minutes but it's one of the
major schools of antiquity
they also have the distinction of being
taken as an opponent by pretty much
every other school of antiquity so i'm
talking about the epicureans
and they um
you know
they ended up drawing fire from just
about everybody you could say there's a
handout if you if you want it right
there for you okay um
now
it's not a systematic perspective
on anger as the two that we looked at
last
the last two sessions the aristotelian
and the stoic perspectives we have in
part because we have more of their texts
we don't have an awful lot of epicurus's
writings
um
but there's still you know a larger
philosophical perspective that's
reflected in i only have one hand up for
you this time and a little bit you know
underachieving compared to previous
times but um they do have a systematic
perspective you know it was a
a uh philosophical school that thought
about
things in in you know broad senses and
tried to bring things together and
having a lot of opponents that they had
to fight with all the time sharpened
their perspective as well
but they don't have an awful lot to say
directly about anger until we get to one
particular work
so as usual what we'll do is about an
hour of presentation maybe a little
longer if we go on some digressions and
then if we have time we'll do a half
hour of question and answer or open
discussion
so the main topics are the sources for
understanding epicurean philosophy how
do we actually get at this stuff
there's a really interesting story there
um we'll do sort of a general overview
of epicureanism as a philosophical
school so we'll talk about their history
a bit and their their doctrines
then we'll look at this guy epicurus
what did he actually have to say
um about anger and connected topics um
the two main things i'm interested in
with him are the issue of divine anger
which he doesn't say an awful lot about
but is important for him
and then how does anger as an emotion
fit into his moral theory
and then we'll look at three other
thinkers
or
texts at least that fit into
the you know the epicurean tradition one
is by a non-epicurean cicero we've
encountered him before when we looked at
stoicism
sister was an eclectic he does have a
lot of epicureans doing some talking as
as dialogue partners in his uh uh
pieces almost always as the guy who
takes the fall because cicero hates the
the epicureans but he does represent
them and it's fortunate that he did
because otherwise we have lost even some
of those doctrines um lucretius is a
poet he writes on the nature of things
he's a roman poet really a contemporary
with cicero
and then there's this guy phillip damos
who was an actual epicurean philosopher
also contemporary with these two guys
and he wrote a text on anger
unfortunately we don't have all of it
and i'll tell you the story of that in
just a few minutes
so if we think about our sources for
epicurean philosophy
epicurus was one of the most prolific
authors of antiquity
and unfortunately we possess
just um
five or six pieces of his work
if you count his last will and testament
as as a piece
we have three letters
um two of which have more to do with
physics and natural philosophy one of
which has to do with moral topics
we have a piece called the principle
doctrines sometimes it's called the
sovereign maxims in other translations
and that is um 40 short passages so it's
sort of like epic epictetus and caridian
the handbook you know this is a popular
thing back in ancient times give a
really short summary of stuff
and
then we also have this this vatican
sayings which is a longer text um 81
passages discovered in a 14th century
manuscript in the vatican library
um some you know quite quite a while ago
um that's a fortunate fine because if we
didn't have that we'd be missing a lot
of stuff but even still it's pretty
short
and then there's you know fragments
occurring in other attacks people say
well epicurus said you know such and
such and thank god they put that in
there because otherwise we wouldn't have
that passage
you know epicurus wrote at least as much
as any other philosopher in antiquity
and that's all we possess and one of the
reasons why we possess what we do have
is because this guy diogenes liertes who
was a um
you know he wrote his lives of
philosophers and he wasn't a very
original thinker he was just trying to
you know present what people had said
he copied out word for word these three
letters and the principal doctrines and
the will
and if he hadn't done that we wouldn't
have any of that stuff
we'd only know about epicurus from from
legends you know the way that we know
about um
antisthenes or diogenes the cynic we
don't have any ancient cynic texts you
know that's all they wrote stuff and we
just lost it you know
so that's important stuff um and then
we've got this guy phillip davis of
gadara
um
in the 18th century
they discovered his manuscripts in the
ruins of a villa in
herculaneum buried by the the eruption
of vesuvius in 79 bc so they found all
these you know big scrolls
that had been you know sort of shoved
into like almost like cubby holes that
was one way you'd store them at the time
and
when they started to roll them they
began to disintegrate so they realized
well there's something here but we can't
do anything with it unfortunately on
anger was one of the scrolls that they
managed to mess up that way
and unless we find another place
that has
some ancient scroll like that which
could happen you know
we don't know what's in the first part
of it
they do have the technology now to
what they did in
before to to give what we do have was
they would do this special process of
trying to moisten it and then unroll it
very slowly
and so you know that
bore some dividends now they've got
some computer technique apparently
that can do some you know amazing
imaging where you don't have to unroll
the scroll i have no idea how it works
but i'm happy because that means that
we'll get access to text that we haven't
seen
for
you know 2000 years
so that would be pretty cool to see
what's in those texts but unfortunately
unless he had a duplicate on anger
you know the first portion is lost
cicero like i said uh was not an
epicurean cicero was what we call an
eclectic philosopher we had an
interesting conversation about that last
time about you know is that a good thing
or a bad thing being eclectic
and so cicero you know eclectic means
you pick out a bit of this and a bit of
this and you bring it all together he
liked aristotle and the aristotelians he
liked the stoics a lot he liked the
skeptics to a certain degree he didn't
like the epicureans so the epicureans
are almost always the people who speak
first in his dialogues because when
you're the guy who talks first you're
usually going to be the guy who gets
knocked knocked down right
and so he has a couple dialogues where
there's an epicurean character and these
are usually people who he knew in in
real life
in the book on ends the first two books
concerned the epicurean school and he's
got this guy torquatus as presenting it
and it presents
a
more or less orthodox uh epicurean
position
it may actually represent epicurus's
book
lost to us
on the end on the the purpose
you could say
on the nature of the gods is another
interesting dialogue and he's got an
epicurean at the very beginning of that
who presents the epicurean position and
then doesn't say much through the rest
of the dialogue
um we can also learn about the epicurean
doctrines and personalities way of life
from sources that are not epicurean and
when when they're not epicurean they're
usually hostile to the epicureans
they're usually quoting uh epicurus or
somebody else to say look at how bad
these guys are
so some examples would be this guy
athenaeus there's a book called that's
translated as sofis at dinner
it's the the dais no sophista
um
is meal and it portrays the epicureans
as being very harsh in conveying truth
um and there was also like a whole
literature
sort of presenting
philosophers at dinner parties behaving
very badly if you ever read lucian of
sam sosta he's a satirist he'll have
like you know dinner party where all the
members of the major philosophical
schools are there
and um
come on in i don't know where to sit um
maybe right there okay
um
yeah which is another challenge
so
you know epicureans when we
this is actually a good spot to talk
about how the word has changed over time
when we use it in our culture we usually
think about people who are you know
really what we now call foodies right
they're they're into
really fancy meals the best wine you
should probably have some some good
music playing at the same time kind of
people throw dinner parties
and um
that's not what it actually meant back
then although they were accused quite
often of being um you know just lovers
of pleasures of all sorts the kind of
people who just be partying all the time
um as it turns out that's not the kind
of life that they they really advocated
or lived they did think pleasure was the
good but it's a certain kind of pleasure
refined kind of pleasure
so we you know we learned something
about the epicureans by looking at the
negative portrayals of them
because every once in a while they'll
say
you know here's what those guys actually
said in this work and and you know we
were fortunate to have those fragments
so as a major school of philosophy and
antiquity like i said before it's a
non-socratic school so it means it
doesn't trace itself back to socrates
plato's school of course plato is a
student of socrates right so that's a
that's a socratic school
aristotle's school is an offshoot of
plato school so it's got a lineage going
back to socrates
um the stoics you know
they are socratic in in a couple
different lineages there's you know they
they go back to the the cynics
who go back to socrates through
antisthenes and also through this this
uh mergarian school
the skeptic school for the most part
takes place within plato's academy and
so that's socratic as well and all these
schools will base themselves
in part by thinking of socrates as
the guy who represents philosophy
epicurus it's it's that's not a concern
for them socrates is not a hero for them
at all
instead they go back to this guy
democritus this atomist philosopher
who was you know a materialist he
thought everything was atoms atom just
means that which cannot be cut
uh comes from ah and then
which means to cut in greek
and um
epicurus adopted some of his ideas and
then developed a perspective of his own
he said that he was self-taught
and it may in fact be the case that he
was a lot of other people who didn't
like him said no no he got his ideas
from this guy or that guy and they were
second rate so you know typical jealousy
going on there now he taught in a couple
places he taught in a place called uh my
talene and he was asked politely to
leave um and then he taught in lanzachus
where he got quite a few followers and
friends and then he wound up in in
athens
and he was of
of athenian citizenship but he lived
most of his life outside of athens his
parents were you know
immigrants right that's yeah
but they had athenian citizenship
so when he's in athens he buys this
garden
and you you'll sometimes hear the
epicurean school is called the garden as
opposed to the stoa or
the academy for plato or the lyceum
and he bought this garden and he'd have
all his friends come there and they'd
hang out and do philosophy and and live
together and so that's where the school
had its its founding
um
he devotes himself to teaching and
writing and friendships
um he had a really good close friend
this guy metro doris of lomsakis who is
an early popularizer of epicurus's
philosophy
he would have been epicurus's successor
but he dies before epicurus
unfortunately
and he leaves a son behind named
epicurus you can tell how much he likes
epicurus and a daughter who are both
provided for in epicurus's will
epicurus his his will and testament says
who is supposed to be supported by the
garden and
it it became something like a um
i don't want to say cult in the negative
sense but you know where there's a very
strong
um
ethos behind it
they view themselves as as kind of a
society
they're very close to each other
and there's a continuity to it going on
so it wasn't just a philosophical school
it was it was like a whole society
they even celebrated his birthday as um
like an annual event
epicurus comes to be seen as a sort of
savior figure to them over time
and then you know like like the other
schools there's you know successors
uh in the garden um they were they were
usually called the successors not the
skull arts as in the other ones and the
epicureans spread out uh as as as a
greek and roman culture spread out
throughout the the middle east
and the entire mediterranean
so you find epicureans in places like
alexandria and alexandria is a very
important city you know we think about
the library of alexandria but there was
a library there in part because there
was such a huge scholarly community
um so there's epicureans there there's
epicureans in syria there's epicureans
in rome
and it becomes quite influential in
roman circles so you know this guy
torquatus uh the character in cicero's
on ends is a good example
it also influences medicine there was an
epicurean um doctor called um
esclepiades of bithya who is trying to
develop epicurean medicine and bring it
to rome and what we mean by epicurean
medicine was a different model
of medicine than what the other people
were working with which actually was
pretty
um
pretty oriented towards looking at what
we nowadays call mental illness and
trying to find remedies for for dealing
with that unfortunately we don't really
have anything
uh we have references to him but we
don't have his works
um
julius caesar was was viewed as being
too too receptive to the epicureans
um when he was a young man he came up on
trial and that was something that came
out in
the trial you know
um as opposed to like you know cato the
stoic you know um epicureanism was kind
of frowned upon poets were influenced
like horus uh the guy carpe diem
uh that's seen as an epicurean kind of
sentiment
um so they become rivals and critics to
the other schools and
what's interesting is
with you know
with the end of the ancient period the
epicureans essentially disappear
um
you know we know that in the end of
antiquity uh it's not just christianity
but a lot of other religious concepts
are floating out there
um people take a a different attitude
towards things epicureans
just sort of like lose their following
and also become seen as as you know very
materialist and and kind of retrobate
and not really where philosophy is
in the renaissance there's there's a
revival of epicureanism so renaissance
philosophy
you're going to find people like pierre
gascendy who's a priest by the way um
who become epicureans and they they
adopt an epicurean position and try to
resuscitate it and there are people
today who it's not like the neo-stoic
movement i would say there but there are
some people today who identify
themselves as epicureans
um
i don't actually know any personally
myself i know a lot of people who
identify themselves as epicureans in the
other sense like they're foodies
people over at the culinary institute of
america but i don't know any that are
super into epicurean philosophy
but i know they're out there
so so what were the the key things that
these guys believed um
one thing
is like i said they were materialists
they thought everything is material um
they believe that everything is a matter
of atoms and they're all sort of falling
in the void so there's two metaphysical
principles atoms and the void
and then to account for freedom they
said um every once in a while and adam
swerves no explanation for why this
happens
but you know it just happens once in a
while and that's what affords us freedom
that's why there's no determinism or
fate the way a lot of people believed
they also
they do believe in the gods
but they believe the gods are very
different than how the poets portrayed
them or some of the other schools of
philosophy portrayed them the gods are
not interested in human affairs because
they're gods
because to be a god
means to be this blessed being who's
enjoying
you know this blissful state and it
would just you know drag you down to get
involved with the world in human affairs
so the gods are sort of like human
beings that just have it really really
good and and you know have i guess a
gated community up in the heavens or
something
they don't let any of the riff-raff in
because the riff-raff would you know
distract them
so there's no sense praying to them
because they're not gonna you know
they're not gonna listen
and
you know going to the temple if you like
going to the temple that's fine but
don't tell all these stories about the
things that gods do because they don't
really do anything other than enjoy
themselves
and so this is a good good you know
intro to their moral theory
they are what we call hedonists
hedonists believe that the good is
essentially pleasure
so
there's a lot of varieties of this and
we'll talk about how epicuruses isn't
just the
party all night kind of variety um
but you know hedonism
it's there's a whole tradition of of
philosophical
theories that say that pleasure is the
good and pain is the evil
and everything else if it's good it's
good because it leads to pleasure or
alleviates pain and if it's bad it's you
know these the reverse
now they devoted a lot of attention to
physics to natural philosophy
uh in in part to have a a pursuit that
was enjoyable because it's you know it's
fun to sit around and speculate about
stuff and try to work out doctrines if
you're into that sort of thing but they
also did that because they wanted
epicurus in particular this is why he
was seen as a savior figure
he wanted to free human beings of these
fears about natural phenomena and the
gods getting angry and taking you know
vengeance or
you know uh being jealous of human
beings a lot of people at that time were
living their lives
in considerable fear and so when there's
you know lightning this is one of the
things that they speculated quite about
what what's what's going on in lightning
is it really zeus you know getting ready
to punish somebody
or is it just a purely natural
phenomenon
yeah in many respects the epicureans are
our forerunners of um
some of the some of the modern atheist
movements
was there a big population of epicureans
then
um
well that's a good question so
the garden itself
we don't know how many people lived
there because only a few are named
but you know we can imagine that it was
like a large household
you know um
so maybe
let's say we estimate it like 50 or 100
people in the garden which is ongoing
and then there's people you know
we might call them freelancers you know
out in the culture
yeah
and so
it's hard to say how many there were but
it was you know
in the ancient world
um for people who are looking for some
sort of meaning to life
these these major philos philosophical
schools were one of the big
um
big alternatives you know religions
provided another thing
you could also just like you know try to
pursue you know rank position glory that
sort of thing but a lot of people were
into
philosophy there's there were probably a
lot who were
like you know not that serious students
who just like heard some of the message
and they were like yeah it sounds great
i'm gonna drink you know
let's have some dinner parties you know
but but i think there were always quite
a few
um
who really were trying to live an
epicurean life what were you saying yeah
i was going to say what i meant was
like more in the fundamentalist
religious type you know there were the
floods because
people are being bad and you know
claiming you know this is because you're
gay well that's why we're having this
that's
which would be similar to
yeah the epicureans were
trying to dispel those kinds of fears
because that was very yeah it was common
to see
natural phenomena as
in some way
oriented towards human beings as you
know like okay there's an earthquake
poseidon must be ticked off you know
what did we do you know
um it's probably that guy over there and
that's what i mean certain schools of
thought today are erupting sort of going
back in time talking well i think that's
always been around
that that notion of um
yeah i mean we can find that in the
american colonies in in
not just in puritan literature but even
in in uh um you know more widespread
literature and then we can find the data
saying no that's not how how things work
you know and so there's that
that same
um
struggle is born out interestingly
jefferson identified himself as an
epicurean
um
i don't know exactly i don't know his
work well enough to know whether he was
really an orthodox epicurean or but he
called himself one so
yeah
so let's um
let's go on a little bit there's a
couple other things i want to bring up
about their doctrines before we get to
anger one of the points that epicurus
really stressed is about death
you know we have fears about natural
phenomena and the gods and you can
dispel those by understanding how things
work but death is not something we can
escape he talks about
with respect to death we're all cities
without walls
um there's no there's no getting away
from it so maybe that should cause us
anxiety and trouble and epicurus says no
because here's a sort of dilemma
either
you're not dead yet
in which case you don't need to worry
about death
because you're not dead yet you're not
experiencing it
or
you're dead
and
what it means to be dead is there's no
you
so there's nothing around to actually
suffer death
death just means the the end of your
existence so there's no point at all in
being uh concerned with it and you know
you might say well then why'd you write
a will you know that's one of the rich
words that some people do yeah a sister
who actually has that in his odds you
know but um yeah he wanted to you know
provide for his his friends
um
now
their goal in in life was to have a
state of what he called ataraxia which
means being untroubled so it's it's
hedonism
it's aiming at pleasure but it's aiming
at a kind of pleasure that is going to
be
you know uninterrupted
and
untroubled by pains by fears it's more
of a
uh a negative thing although
um it's not you know it's sort of like
you know when you get to lay down after
a really rough day and
you're you know maybe
your joints kind of hurt and stuff like
that and you get in the bed and you just
like lay down and now you're at rest how
good that feels
that's an example of optoroxia
or when you've got all your bills paid
for the month
and there's actually still some money
left in the account and you don't have
any worries about you know what's going
to happen or how you're going to pay you
know this or that
um
that's antoraxia there's a lot of other
examples we could give
so um he will make a distinction between
two types of pleasure this is some of
the stuff that i have in the handout for
you which you don't need to necessarily
look at right now but for future
reference
he talked about um
moving or kinetic pleasures
and
static pleasures so like laying in bed
after a long day that would be a static
pleasure
right
getting up and
having a drink would be
a moving pleasure you're doing something
it's active
and epicurus thought that um the static
pleasures are quite often
a removal of pain or a removal of
trouble
um they're they're you know they're not
an act of
getting some pleasure
doing something that will bring about
pleasure it's more removal of pain but
he says that's more pleasurable
in in the long run than just you know
going out and doing active uh things you
know eating drinking
having sex um going to a museum and
running your eyes all over things you
know
those he thought
are
less pleasurable in in many respects um
he also made a distinction between
pleasures and pains of the body and the
mind
the body does feel pleasures and pains
uh and and when you talk about the mind
the mind is in the body he thought it
was like little you know even finer
particles spread throughout the whole
body you know his psychology probably
doesn't doesn't work for us today right
because we have a whole different theory
of things he probably nowadays say well
it's that brain of yours you know that's
doing things he thought the the center a
lot of ancients did the center uh
consciousness was here
um
but you're not not up here where we we
place them the hedonisms seem to
have their pleasure until they die like
they could yeah they move into death
ideally you do yeah
yeah ideally you would have like a life
that's got no
worries no unnecessary pains and then
you know sort of the sprinkling here and
there of active pleasures but none that
are going to cause you problems so like
you know you have you have a glass of
wine with dinner but you don't drink the
whole bottle so you're not hungover the
next day right because that's a pain um
you um
you know you you you listen to some
music but you don't get yourself so
wound up with music that you need to go
to a concert and you know wait in line
and and be there with a whole bunch of
other sweaty fans bumping around and
stuff like that right so yeah
the goal would be to have a life like
that um
it may not be that realizable for some
people
doesn't uh a carpet diem which i think
means thieves today yeah imply
the uh idea that you should try to
enjoy what you can enjoy before it falls
apart and you have to experience pain i
think a lot of people tend to interpret
it as like
you know
um party as hard as you can today
because who knows what's gonna happen
tomorrow but you're right the original
idea is that you find it horus is
we don't know what's gonna happen
tomorrow so you know enjoy what you can
now
so going back to physical and mental
pleasures
epicurus says one of the key things with
mental pleasures
that makes them
superior
to physical pleasures is the factor of
time
when you're feeling a physical bodily
pleasure you can only feel it in the
present
think about when you're eating something
that you you really enjoy eating right
there's a couple different things that
go on one is that the first bite the
second bite the third bite those are the
best and by the time that you get to the
end of the dish it doesn't taste quite
the same
for a lot of dishes
interestingly like
coke and pepsi remember when they used
to do those taste tests
they found
that
pepsi would usually win
if people just took a sip
because pepsi is sweeter
but if you had to drink a whole like
little cup like a dixie cup of it
coke would win
coke has more or bitterness and the
bitterness and sweetness are a little
bit more balanced pepsi was viewed as
too sweet over over time you know um
but then you know so let's say it's
something else that you're eating right
you eat it and while you're eating it
that's great but then it's gone
right and so what do you do after that
you know um well you eat some more
yeah and you can now you can remember
the taste of it but that's a mental
pleasure that's no longer your tongue
actually doing something that's you
remembering it and you can anticipate it
and that's another kind of pleasure as
well right that's also mental pleasure
and the things that we enjoy through the
mind like you know for example
friendship there's a lot of pleasures
involved in friendship those aren't just
bodily pleasures those are mental
pleasures you're you're connected with
that that person
where's that sound coming from
somebody's phone
that next door
no maybe
a party
oh okay
well we've got we have a soundtrack
so that that's an important thing to
keep in mind
um he also distinguishes between desires
he talks about
desires that are natural and are
necessary that's one class
desires that are
uh
wow it's really getting up
desires that are
natural but not necessary and desires
that are neither natural nor necessary
and
the desires that are neither
neither natural nor necessary those are
the ones that get us in trouble
because they're based on what he calls
groundless or vain or empty opinion so
you know he gives like you know a couple
examples the notion that you should you
should eat something a good idea right
the notion that you should just like eat
and eat and eat and eat as much as you
possibly can that's a baseless opinion
that's that's not that's not a true
opinion
uh it's not grounded in something and
it'll get you in trouble especially if
it's guiding your desires
and if you think about our culture
you know what does advertising do
it the whole purpose of advertising is
to create desire where desire did not
yet exist or to awaken desire and the
way you do it is by creating beliefs and
feelings in people's minds but hey this
would be good for me
and i would enjoy this
and so epicurus is kind of giving us a
manual for how to avoid being taken in
by what our culture is throwing at us he
says we need to restrict ourselves to
the desires that are either natural and
necessary like you gotta eat
you know and you do have a desire to eat
good good
that you do because otherwise you're
gonna die right
or somebody's gonna have to force feed
you
and then desires that are um
natural but not necessary we you know we
can follow those two we just shouldn't
make those the priority
we should restrict ourselves as much as
possible to the desires that are natural
and necessary and natural you know
covers a wide ground for him
so this leads to this really famous
saying of his he says a person cannot
live pleasantly
without living prudently that is with
practical wisdom
well carlos in greek which could mean
beautifully as well
and justly
so if you really want to have a
hedonistic lifestyle
if you want to have full pleasure you
have to be prudent in it you have to
have a good way of life and you have to
be just
you have to
follow some rules
yeah go ahead well
explaining hedonism
like that
uh
that sounds like a good thing
but the way i think we the way it's
evolved over time is that if you're you
know hedonistic you're
only thinking of yourself or your own
pleasures and stuff like that's how i
was raised to think about being that way
there was a guy uh aristippus who who
predates
epicurus was a student of socrates who
somehow got the message from socrates
that pleasure was the only good and he
was a hedonist like that he said bodily
pleasures are where it's at
try to heap up as many of them as
possible you know you want to structure
your life so you're having one bodily
pleasure after another
he got criticized for like hanging out
with prostitutes and he says you know
why would i why would i marry i mean
this is exactly what i want right i can
get it as a business transaction you
know that was sort of the hugeness of my
favorite time i think that's what we
picked up yeah so there's always two
different things and the epicureans were
always being accused of being
of evidence by other people you know
don't you have to be persistent in
wanting this i mean yeah
epicurus actually narrow yourself down
to that goal i mean you don't have any
interferences
well you you're gonna have interferences
you just it's more like when you get off
track you gotta make sure you come back
on track right
um just like when you let's say you're
trying to have a healthy diet yeah
most of us are going to fail at one time
like the holidays right but then there's
a question you say ah screw it you know
i've left the diet
i'm never going back to it there's no
point no you you guided yourself back to
it and say okay now i gotta get back on
track
epicurus actually says unless we
make sure
to follow these these doctrines
our
our desire is not going to match up with
our way of life you know the way of life
that we want to live so you're you're
entirely right it's going to take some
discipline
and some application
prudence is supposed to help us out with
that so prudence is practical wisdom
it's supposed to teach us like how to
judge rightly between pleasures do i
do i sleep in even though i know i know
i need to do some work and work doesn't
seem all that fun
well you know the work needs to get done
and that will lead to greater pleasures
later that's behaving crude i don't see
any accountability as if you're a
hedonist you have no accountability but
to yourself
well you could have accountability to
others it's there's no inherent
accountability to it but if you have
friends
um you know epicurus thought friendship
was the greatest of pleasures and you
can't be a good friend if you're just
like
being totally self-indulgent you know
even if you just see your friends as
only a source of pleasures and not
valued in for their own sake you're not
going to be a good friend
so you're right for a lot of epicureans
at a low level there's probably not
going to be accountability except
oneself
um
but there's the possibility of that you
know if you have good friendships he
also does talk about justice right and
so what he means by justice is
not harming other people not not
allowing yourself to be harmed it's a
kind of social contract that each
society has about you know what what's
going to keep people from harming each
other
and he says rather unconvincingly that
you really should be just because if
you're not then you're always going to
be worried about getting caught
and i know there's plenty of people who
don't worry about being
you know
or don't care you know uh
but he you know he tends to think that
if you're being
bad to people
um
you may get some temporary pleasure out
of it it's not going to pay off in the
long run you know
as a matter of fact he told he advocated
don't get involved in politics at all
because you're never going to be happy
in politics
i was just going to get that i mean
isn't the context
the people who had the
uh
the luxury to indulge in philosophy and
so forth yeah
was of course the elite
uh by some sense life was extremely
precarious yeah
the masses lived
you know the contrast between the
average person
so it
seems in some ways it's a very balanced
approach for someone most of these
people could do
more or less what they wanted
although
you know if you
if you weren't a slave who was like you
know totally
without freedom because you had a bad
master or something like that because
quite a few slaves did have quite a
quite a bit of freedom
um and you took on epicurus's uh
let's call it his system right you know
think about it sort of like the
self-help systems that we see out there
today because that's really what it's
like
it advocates living a very simple life
so you don't need a lot of money to do
it
as a matter of fact you you don't want
to be spending your time on trying to
make a ton of money
because the pleasures that you you know
once you remove pain from from the
situation and worry and trouble
um
you just need some simple pleasures and
they will take on
they'll take on a much greater
um
value for you
you know he he he's the kind of guy
who'd sit around just eat a pot of
cheese and he'd be like you know you
could imagine him going to hannaford and
getting like a tin of cottage cheese and
just sitting there and eating that
saying this is really good i'm in that
bacon
yeah
yeah
or maybe a jar of pickles yeah um so
it's it's it's a lifestyle that would be
possible for many people
to live
um
of course if you are a slave you're kind
of you're kind of screwed because you've
got somebody who's going to make trouble
for you your master right or business
but for most of the
if you're living it the right way it's
doable for most people if if you're
living it like the you know
got a party all the time that's very
expensive well not only that if you if
you live like well you know i love sex
and i want to have it whenever i want
and if my friend's wife wants it why
this is pleasure you don't have any if
you don't add the other
epicurus is not
interesting that he was not a big fan of
sex
he actually tells a young man
you know you can follow your sexual
passion if you want
and try to do it as prudently as
possible but you're if you think about
it
you're you're almost always going to
cause trouble for yourself and he like
lists a few different you know things
that it's likely to lead to and we've
all had we've all had that you know
message when we were uh
younger and then probably a lot of us
ignored it and from experience we can
say
you know there's there's something to
that you know
um
and he he uh
yeah he sees sex as something that is
natural but not necessary
um
now you could say well what about the
human race wouldn't it be nice to
continue
so then in that sense it is it is
necessary
and um
he would say like most of the things
that people call fetishes totally
unnecessary
just setting people up for all sorts of
problems you know or like you know or
like you know screwing around right
flandering he would say that's that's a
recipe for disaster because you know
think about how many ways you can you
can get yourself in trouble with that
all that you're describing seems to be
a cause and effect without any uh moral
uh code
was there a moral dimension to
yeah well
yeah the justice part is a moral
dimension and if you think that pleasure
is the good and it's good to live a
pleasurable life that is the moral code
okay so there's prudence so he was
defining
moral values in his terms in terms of
pleasure and pain yeah yeah and you know
we're going to see other theories do
that later on down the line like
the whole utilitarian movement
in the 1900s does that sort of thing
so let's now talk about anger
we haven't talked at all about how anger
would be affected
he
talks about the gods of anger um at the
very beginning of the sovereign maxims
he says the gods are free from feeling
anger or favoritism why because these
would imply weakness on their part or a
kind of vulnerability being being able
to get angry
is in some respects a
lack of
you know freedom or a lack of perfection
that the gods don't don't
suffer but we unfortunately do
that quote is going to get used by
epicureans when they have debates among
themselves about the nature of anger
so the upshot of this is we don't have
to be worried about the gods getting
angry with us which is very liberating
isn't it we don't have to worry about
divine wrath
he also says that you know because anger
is a distinctively and
also animal emotion it's not something
that's like woven into the cosmos
so
earthquakes that's not anger uh
lightning that's not anger nobody's
angry at us bad things sometimes happen
but it's not the wrath of the gods
and in the vatican sayings he says if
parents have caused to be angry with
their children
of course it's foolish to resist and
thus not try to beg for forgiveness try
to mollify somebody
but if they
do not have cause and are angry without
reason it's ridiculous to make an appeal
to one who's irrationally opposed to
hearing such an appeal and thus not to
try to convince him by other means of a
spirit of good will so his point is
angry people
some you can deal with some you can't if
they're irrationally angry if they're
angry based on groundless opinion as
we're going to see
um
there's no there's no getting around
that you know you might be able to maybe
take you have them take a walk or you
you leave the situation
um go ahead when you have anger
and you you're able to get rid of it
vent it out then you go back on track
don't you
well
i mean if you don't get rid of that
anger
that is gnawing away at you it works
that way for some people okay
that is that is a idea about anger that
moral theorists and psychologists have
shown in the late 20th century is a
recipe for disaster for many people
because the the idea was that you know
anger is sort of like hydraulics you
vent some of the fluid and then you know
there's less tension
what a lot of the research has shown is
that it doesn't and that people will
actually become angrier and they'll
develop habits of expressing their anger
that way
so it's not always the best for some
people it works um for other people it
actually makes them worse
and depends yeah and if you add two
you have two people in a situation where
they're both angry at each other and you
let them vent each other then they get
even angry at each other sometimes
so
um but you know for some people it can
work
um
that idea of living pleasantly you know
and free of pains and fears
um
if we think about this idea of living
prudently well unjustly
we can ask ourselves how compatible is
this with feeling anger or acting on
anger having an angry disposition or
making other people angry
so if we think about it in terms of the
living well the caulos
or honorably or beautifully anger's not
very attractive
and so
if if our goal is to live pleasantly
and we're getting angry all the time
we're not living well so we're not going
to be living pleasantly
if we think about in terms of prudence
practical wisdom anger seems to involve
some pain and feeling of it
and it also has a really strong tendency
to lead us to
to
thinking out courses of action which
seem pleasant at first i'm gonna i'm
gonna you know i'm gonna show that that
son of a [ __ ] you know
um but then they're gonna lead to
further pains
you know we we embarrass ourselves
we alienate other people from ourselves
we inflict too much
um
damage you know we make stupid business
decisions sometimes based on anger you
know you can't you know you can't tell
me what to do i quit you know
so that may not be compatible with
prudence and then if we think about
anger considered
in terms of living justly
the point of justice for epicurus is
that moral dimension that marvin was
asking about is that we don't harm other
people or or be harmed that we follow
the laws we follow the agreements what's
beneficial and what's useful
so we can ask does anger serve a kind of
social purpose and sometimes it probably
does there's probably some people who
need to be told off right
but in a lot of cases adding anger to
the situation doesn't bring about more
justice at least that's the way epicurus
is it
now another way that's useful to think
about this is that distinction between
kinds of desires
so
some states of anger
would appear to involve either
they would appear to involve those
desires that are neither necessary nor
natural that arise from empty opinions
epicurus uh and the epicureans included
revenge fantasies in this category you
know when people
um get angry and they think about
how am i gonna how am i gonna show that
person
how am i gonna embarrass them how am i
gonna put them in their place
um epicurus thinks that that's that's a
desire that is not going to serve you um
they will talk later on about natural
anger we'll get to that in a minute but
he thinks that it's often based on
groundless desires so what would be an
example of that um i need to be
listened to
uh by everybody uh or people are not
valuing me
so that's that's a belief that some
people have
um but it's not one that's based in
reality
you know and but if you do have that
belief you're probably gonna get angry
pretty easy aren't you because people
aren't going to listen to you most of
the time and then you're going to have a
cause to be
angry with them
and so this is a good example of
unnecessary
anger
so
there's often a lack of natural limit
with these empty opinions and and their
connected desires
here's some examples in the vatican
sayings he says poverty is great wealth
if measured by the goals of nature and
wealth is abject poverty if not limited
by the goals of nature
so you don't really need to have that
much
and if if you do have this this you know
desire to just accumulate and accumulate
and accumulate anybody who gets in your
way is going to make you angry
you know something's bothering me
there's a lot of anger today i mean
there's an anger sure just recently on
tv anger in the walmart there's anger in
the parking spots
where are we in this how do we well
epicurus would say we're not good
epicureans
epicureans that say well most people
aren't epicurus you know they're not
good epicureans and that's that's
at any given time
our culture is not one that's
informed by philosophy very much you
know they're offering this as sort of a
remedy
for for that sort of thing and you're
right i mean
so the idea about road rage right first
you actually have to get on the road
people get mad at each other in the
parking lots you know
what do we call that it's not even it's
not even roam rage yet it's parking lot
range you know
it's something deeper than that though i
mean if you use that as an excuse
there's something else
well i mean
so there's a natural human
reaction of anger right but a lot of a
lot of what feeds into it are our
perspectives on things so we get angry
at people at times that we don't need to
because we have
mistaken beliefs about things like you
know if you have the belief that
everybody should be nice to you all the
time
you're really setting yourself up for
trouble right um because that's i don't
know where people get that belief from
but it's it's not one that's based in
there sort of any sort of uh you know
rational basis that's that's you know
provided to us by evidence um
i think a lot of times that's one of
those cases where desire drives belief
which then drives desire you know
but there's there's all sorts of things
like this and if if we're in a culture
that teaches us
um you're not somebody unless you
have a lot of status
or
a lot of money or
maybe celebrity um and everybody's
jostling with each other that's a
situation where people are going to get
angry with each other that's just it we
have
a one percent that have all of those
things and we have a larger a larger
society that desires those things or
well because they've been told they they
they and because it gives them some kind
of power
they want they want a piece of the
the piece of the action as they say yeah
right he's got a couple other
interesting sayings like this too
it says the stomach is not insatiable as
most people say
instead the opinion that the stomach
needs unlimited filling is false
so
you know this is something that people
can get angry about as well
he says the esteem of others is outside
of our control we must attend instead to
healing ourselves
um and then he says the ingratitude of
the soul makes an animal greedy for
endless variation in its way of life if
we we need to have options all the time
and people are screwing us over if they
don't give us lots and lots of options
you know um we're going to get angry
very easily
so anger you know is not going to be
part of an epicurean life it's not going
to be something you'll never get angry
it's just that it can't be a major part
of it
and it's also going to be a big problem
for the development and enjoyment of
friendships or households and families
and communities because anger tends to
be very disruptive
the last suggestion i have too about
this because we're sort of drawing these
epicurean texts into territory that
didn't go
he brings up the capacity for memory as
we talked about
now
when we think about our our capacity to
get angry
memory sometimes plays into that right
you ever have a fight with a close
friend or a spouse
and now all the baggage from like the
last year starts getting put onto the
table that's because we remember things
you know and you did this then and what
you're doing right now is just another
example of how you
you know view me how you treat me how do
you
yeah
so epicurus would say do we focus on
remembering
past pleasures that's a good thing to
remember past pleasures because that's
pleasant right
or do we focus on remembering past pains
like when people screwed us over or made
us feel humiliated or
treated as unfairly
if we're practicing an epicurean life
we're probably going to develop a kind
of forgetfulness towards
the pains that we've encountered in the
past
in part because usually we can't do
anything about it right the people who
made us angry they're not in positions
where we can get to them and do
something about it so if we just dwell
on it we're allowing them to hurt us
again and
pain is a bad thing for these these
hedonists
um
so let's let's go on to cicero there's
not much to say actually about him um
the day phoenix or the on the ends um
there's some discussion there that gives
us a little bit more detail about
epicurean moral theory um the virtues
wisdom
uh and temperance these would help us to
distinguish between
necessary and unnecessary desires
um they would they would give they would
have some role in helping us not to be
as angry as a result if we're if we're
temperate
if we have control over our desires for
bodily pleasures
like food or drink or sex or you know
laying around all day you know probably
watching tv or netflix or things like
that would be under temperance these
days
we're probably going to be less angry if
we're temperate because we're not tying
ourselves in with things that make us
vulnerable to being disappointed you
know
he also says one who is perpetually
swayed by conflicting and incompatible
councils and desires can know no peace
or call remember that's the goal for the
epicureans
there's a discussion of mental diseases
which includes extravagant and imaginary
desires and among the examples picked
out are the ill-tempered people that in
latin the difficulties the people who
are kind of a pain in the ass you know
they're always sour they've always got
something to be upset about you know
now lucretius has more to say in the on
the nature of things to begin with
epicurus is is cast over and over again
as a savior figure
who's released human beings from having
to live in fear
um
one example of this is he's you know he
thinks of fire and water these basic
principles they they had this you know
four element view
they were atomos but they thought they
were you know things ultimately reducing
the four elements
um he thinks that fire and water are in
strike with each other and at times
overcome each other and the world so the
ancient greeks had the story of this guy
um phaethon who was the son of helios
the son right and faith on wants to
drive his dad's chariot and his dad
agrees to it and of course you know he's
not a good driver so he gets too close
to the earth and starts burning stuff up
and then he goes too high in the heavens
so zeus gets ticked off and kills him
with a thunderbolt and
um
lucretia says
that's a terrible story you know there's
there's a cosmic thing going on here
between you know fire and water uh
sometimes the earth floods sometimes it
gets baked it doesn't have anything to
do with zeus getting angry and throwing
thunderbolts that's just the sort of
thing that's going to screw kids up if
you tell them
and so he says here's what he says about
that poor humanity to saddle the gods
with such responsibilities and to throw
in a vindictive temper
and he says you know this is going to
screw up your religion
if you picture the quiet ones and
they're untroubled pieces tossed on
turbulent waves of anger you will not
approach their temples with a tranquil
heart you're going to go to the temple
trying to you know make sure god doesn't
get ticked off at you you know i think
you know going back to like when you're
talking about contemporary culture i
think a lot of people go to church in
part because um they want to make sure
they stand god's good side or something
these very superstitious notions you
know
um
now his focus on anger tends to be in
terms of physical theory so he thinks
that anger is like a having too much
fire in the system too much hot stuff in
the system
and so he says when we become angry we
boil over with anger from heat he says
that some animals
have a lot of that in their composition
the prime example is the lion that's why
the lion is so ferocious right so angry
all the time
some human beings are like that as well
they have some people have more of that
that disposition they're what we call
cholera right using the theory of the
humors
and he says this can be dealt with to
some degree by education and training
and culture but you cannot entirely
change that
you can reduce it to very small
lingering traces
but
you can't eliminate it entirely
um so a person who's got some anger
problems you know if if they like if
they became an epicurean
they could they could lessen it
they could deal with it but they
couldn't totally eliminate it
now when we get to philadelphus like i
said we don't have this whole work but
it was called on anger so at least here
we've got somebody who's actually
looking directly at anger
unfortunately we lost the first half of
it
um
what we've got there's two main parts to
it the first part is what we call a
diatribe
which is a
rhetorical speech against something
in this case it's against danger that
was a common thing around the second
century and first century bc to write
these diatribes about all sorts of
things against too much salt you know
against alexander against daniel there
were a couple other against angers or on
angers out there where people are like
yeah look at what angry people look like
you know we see this a bit in senecas on
anger a diatribe like that
the other part is what we call a
dialectical examination of anger where
he's canvassing different views and
saying i think they got this part right
but this part wrong
and
it's happening in two interesting ways
with philadelphus
so there's these other philosophical
schools out there and we looked at two
of them just the last two times
um
the the aristotelians
you know think about it like goldilocks
right some some people are like the
porridge is too hot porridge is too cold
just right
here's the epicurean view
the aristotelians with respect to anger
they value it too highly they they think
that it's okay to be angry in a lot of
situations where it's not they identify
it with manliness
they think that you need anger to defend
yourself
um too hot
the stoics say anger is always bad as a
matter of fact it's one of the worst of
the devices and passions get rid of all
your anger it's never reasonable to be
angry
clearly too cold
just right would be the epicurean
position right in the middle you know
um and so here's how he so there's that
right and then the epicureans were
arguing amongst themselves about other
things too so he stakes out a position
in relation to the other epicureans as
what he views as the orthodox epicurean
position
he gives us a definition of anger which
is kind of an interesting one
he calls it a kindling
swelling irritation and indignation
together with a fierce desire to pursue
and contend with the person if one can
um
so there's a lot rolled in there isn't
there but a lot of it's kind of
metaphorical language i think
now here's where it gets really
interesting he makes a distinction
between what he calls natural anger
and empty anger or or vain anger it's
the same word that where epicurus was
talking about
vain or or false
beliefs
the greek word is canos which means
empty or vain um
and
or groundless right so there's natural
anger and then there's groundless anger
natural anger will be felt by the wise
person
as well as other people too but but even
if you're the epicurean wise person the
one who's living the epicurean life
you're going to feel natural anger
it arises as a response to injury or
harm when it is
perceived as being
actually intentional so if i bump into
you
um and you get angry with me
and you you think it's not really my
fault that's not natural anger that's
that's the other type but if you see me
like you know you see me go up and like
trip her and you get angry at that at
that injury that's that's being done
because you say look that guy meant to
do it that would be natural anger
so we're going to have some of that
occurring in part because human beings
are kind of jerks to each other right
um
and it focuses on on punishment which in
greek is colossus
and punishment meant as something like a
medicine a bitter medicine
punishment you're imposing pain to try
to bring about a better result right is
this
excuse me yeah that you're talking about
yes okay
now he's construing this as being
epicurus's position you know oh i see so
it's not epicurus it's the way he's
defining natural and vain yeah i mean
here here's the thing it could be that
um
epicurus might have had something in one
of his texts that we've lost that this
is coming from what he's really doing is
he's taking uh categories from
epicurus that every everybody who was a
good epicurean would know you know like
the natural desires or the empty desires
and he's applying them to the topic of
anger
um
it'd be really cool if we actually had
all of
those tests um
but then we might find that
you know apparently he was epicurus is
not a very good stylist um we might find
them kind of hard to read
but let's talk about empty anger so
he uses two different words for this he
calls it um or gay which is the greek
word for anger or gay kane meaning
meaning empty
um and he also calls this by the greek
term thumbos
thermos and organ are used often as
synonyms but he wants to make a
distinction between them
um
and so the most is always bad the most
is always you know anger that's that's
out of control and he says empty anger
is felt by the the foolish or the
underdeveloped person
not by the sage not by the person who's
developed it arises as a response to
injury or to injustice or to sliding
and it involves some sort of assumption
or perception on the person's part so it
doesn't have to be a response to
something deliberate you know again bump
into you
you're like who the hell are you to bump
into me that would be an example of
of uh empty anger you know it's you know
maybe it's based on the idea that nobody
should ever bump into you you know the
universe you know should have a nice
barrier around you respecting your
personal space clearly
a crazy idea you know because um that's
i don't know where anyone would get that
idea um now
empty anger he says focuses on
on revenge
as opposed to punishment it focuses on
revenge and the greek word that he uses
for that is the one that aristotle used
for defining anger timorasis you know a
rectification setting things right
and he says it could not only come from
empty opinions and beliefs but also a
bad disposition so you know
if you're the kind of person who gets
angry all the time you have a tendency
to
allow bad or false beliefs to make you
react to situations and perceive malice
on the part of people that don't have it
you know
um you're probably not gonna be a good
person to to have in uh
you know
customer service if that's the case
or
or the front of the house you know right
in restaurants you know
you got that sort of thing you can wash
the dishes you can keep the books but
you probably don't need to be dealing
with customers you know
so
now um
he thinks that empty anger is is an evil
in itself
uh
both in itself and because of the
troubles that it brings um
and empty angers he thinks involves some
kind of foolish pleasure which is
imagining and taking revenge
so the stewing that we do the ruminating
you know he thinks that now one of the
one of the great um uh scholars who's
done work on this um this person
uh tsuna suggests that empty anger
involves mistaken beliefs about being
wronged or whether you're being wronged
or not or about the intensity of the
wrong experience that we over value you
know somebody um spills coffee on my my
nice shirt right
that's something that can be easily
remedied just you know wash it and we've
got additives that you can put in it's
not the end of the world but people do
react as if it's the end of the world
right so that would be a good example of
a mistaken belief at work um
they also get mistaken about the
potential for pleasure and retaliation
people will think to themselves boy if i
can just show that person
that's going to be so great and then you
get it i think a lot of us have gone
through this experience you get it and
it's it's really not that enjoyable
sometimes you actually feel bad for the
person
after you've you know hurt them in
response
and you don't want to you don't want to
let on because then you know you'd have
to apologize yourself
and you've just made them you know
the bad person
so um philodemus views angers both as
actually getting angry and is the
disposition
so because of these false beliefs
some people can get enraged about
anything there are some people who was
like they're always getting angry i
think you probably know some people like
that
other people he says can get angry and
stay angry for years
we've seen this sometimes in like you
know family disputes
um co-workers can you know be a problem
that way
so
what's really interesting is he
he not only discusses how anger happens
and makes this distinction
he wants to provide some sort of
treatment for anger
and he um he views it as a something
like a moral disease but also is what we
would nowadays call mental illness you
know the greeks didn't recognize a
you know strong distinction as we often
do in our culture between those they saw
them as sort of a continuum
and the treatment would be
partly rational persuasion you know if
you think about what cognitive behavior
therapy
if any of you have ever used that does
to try to deal with anger management you
try to analyze
your beliefs that are leading you to
being angry and see whether they're
rational or not and hopefully if you can
see that they're irrational it makes you
less angry or you don't act on the anger
at least
and partly he says it has to consist in
this this technique of setting before
the eyes
which is using the imagination to create
or or evoke a repugnance and other
aspects in relation to anger
so
when we looked at the stoics we saw
seneca advocating having a person look
in the mirror when they're angry that's
one way to bring you know the angry
visage before the eyes there's other
ways to do it as well
look at somebody else who's angry and
then realize that you probably look like
that person
and then there's supposed to be some
sort of you know some sort of um
act reactive
you know uh reaction to that where you
say oh i don't want to be like that
that's that's not who i am and that can
help you to be less angry
um
he argues that we ought to engage in
treatment when a person is actually
angry and here he differed with some of
the other epicureans some of them said
look once a person's lost their temper
is nothing you can do you know forget it
he says no this is actually the best
time to do it because now you can start
to reshape the
perceptions and the habits and the ways
that their
their psyche works
another interesting feature is that
philodemus very explicitly criticizes
anger that's being exhibited towards
wives towards children and towards
slaves
so he's very conscious
of power dynamics in ancient society
we can see that he's affirming the
importance of the value of family and
household relationships and the
vulnerability of of um
to anger's effects by those who are are
in a position to get angry that the male
householder is the one who gets to be
angry the slave doesn't get to be angry
because if they do then they'll get you
know
put down or something like that he's
also being very attentive to the
vulnerability of all the people who are
in the one down position
the women the children and the slaves
um and he's very clear about this he he
he would say
um
if you're an epicurean
you cannot be taking anger out on
people who are vulnerable to you like
you know maybe employees right you can
kick your employees around or one way
people often
vent their angers they go out to a
restaurant then they treat the waiter or
the waitress like like crap you know
or other customer service people
he would say that's that's something you
really have to watch
um he also thinks that anger can be a
major impediment to education
and so i have a few other remarks let me
uh since we have a little bit of time
i'll tell you about another work that he
he has called on frank criticism
or the greek word for that is parasia
freedom of speech and sometimes
translated
and
if you're if you're trying to
tell people that the way that they're
living is not 100 correct
and they need to change some of it and
some of that's rooted in the way that
they typically react to things
sooner or later you've you've actually
got to got to you know tell people hey
you're screwing up this is this is not
the way you should be behaving
so
now of course that doesn't guarantee
they'll listen to you
as we all know from having been on both
sides of that i think um but sometimes
you actually have to as we say call a
spade a spade
you have to say to somebody look the way
you're behaving uh it's it's it's
actually bad it's bad for you it's bad
for the other people that's what what
he's calling parisia it's like
intervention
yeah an intervention would have to
include that it couldn't be a very
effective intervention if you just
escaped around
you never actually got to the point of
saying
okay
this is sort of like imagining an
intervention like the person comes in
and everybody's sitting there and some
cookies and some coffee and they're like
well it's nice that you all came over
what's going on well we wanted to talk
to you about some stuff you know there's
a few things that are making us
uncomfortable these days oh really what
are those
we don't really want to burden with them
you know um let's uh let's talk about
how your life is going and they never
had them you know after an hour or so
they're like
well this is a nice chat
that wouldn't be a very good
intervention with it
well so you know that's actually a good
way to put it those intervention the the
epicurean
practitioner is kind of intervening in
the student's life
so philadelphus rejects what he calls
harshness
in in um this intervention or
exhortation when rather frankness is
being called force he's distinguishing
between
you know you can tell people the same
content and do it in a way that's
what we call assertive
as opposed to aggressive or overly
hostile or confrontational or
you know in ways that are just putting
people down
you know you can say look buddy you've
got anger problems and you need to work
on it or you can say wow you're just a
complete jerk and so one would be
um frankness and the other one would be
harshness that's showing sensitivity
yeah and some people don't have that you
know
honesty without compassion
i thought that was a good thing yeah
that would that would fit into this yeah
um there is a kind of
brutality a kind of um reduction to our
animal nature in in harshness uh the
epicureans would say
he also criticizes the
you know where it's starting to escape
too close to the edge he says that young
people have a tendency to start out with
frankness and then it easily shifts into
um a kind of abusive
harshness
and he says some people can't
distinguish between these in two
different ways they can't tell when
they're doing it
so they're the person who says oh i'm
just being honest with everybody and
then you're like no you're a jerk you
talk to people in terrible ways
you know here's how you could say it
instead like you know with some
compassion for example right
uh or some empathy
um and then other people can't
distinguish it um when other people are
are criticizing them they can't
distinguish between
frankness telling people what they need
to hear
and just you know coming down hard on
them and so anytime you criticize them
they get they get upset or angry
now he says that some teachers or some
students can't take frank's speech by
their teachers or fellow students and
these include people who have anger
problems
this is something i've seen on both
sides again
we're talking about this
when i was
a student
i actually
did quite a few of the things that i now
find to be kind of a pain in the butt
that students do in my classes and so i
have to be a little bit more receptive
to them doing that and forgiving because
i did these things
and one of them is taking offense too
easily
and some students
are like that you know you give them you
know you give them a c on their paper
because their paper wasn't very good
you know and it didn't fulfill the
criteria that would be required for a b
or an a and then they get mad
because you know they they don't want to
hear that their paper
um wasn't what they thought it was you
know
um i remember actually in
if you're just feeling enraged um
when i was a graduate student i had to
take these these uh
various tests at the master's level you
had one test and then four at the phd
level
and it was the masters was called the
comps the comprehensive and you had to
write about you know ancient philosophy
medieval philosophy modern philosophy in
19th century you get like a list of
questions and you would pick one from
from each of those
and i got a low pass and i thought i'd
done so great on it
and and some of the criteria they would
like they would show you the greatest
remarks so like some of them were
actually quite frankly you know
not not very well grounded you know like
one person was upset because my first uh
sentence when in this this discussion
about plato was 16 lines long so too
long for a sentence it was
well constructed
now you know
on the other hand perhaps that is too
long perhaps that's that's too unwieldy
not everybody wants to be reading cicero
when they're grading a test and i'm very
attentive to that now as a teacher
grading other people's stuff
i want things to be fairly
straightforward you know i don't want to
a display of eloquence you know i want
to see that the student knows their
thing
but i remember just being you know for
days i was just irate about that but
that's because i have anger problems you
know other students would get that and
it would just roll off their back
when i came to the prelims i ended up
with uh
three high passes in a pass because i
did things differently and
by then i got some of that dealt with
he also talks about the the
the teacher cannot afford to be angrily
disposed towards students
in part it sets a bad example
if the epicurean way of life is supposed
to actually make you into a calmer
happier person and you're losing your
temper with your students
clearly it's not working so why the hell
should they do it you know you always
have to give a person
like to save safe face like the japanese
oh yeah yeah
there has to be some way of letting
letting the anger
sort of melt away in a way by saving
faces not pinpointing what their errors
are and everything like that not
humiliating anyone that's that's the way
to figure it out
you have to have a way out
there's a there's a technique that's
used these days um
called sandwiching
and it's becoming so prevalent that now
it doesn't really work very well because
people see it coming
and it's if you're going to criticize
somebody
you got the criticism in the middle
that's the meat
and then you got something nice that you
say at the beginning and something that
you're nice something nice that you say
at the end right so there's a sandwich
there like science hood it's not you
it's me
that's another way to do it too
yeah
um
i mean in some cases
you're right you don't want to you don't
want to unduly humiliate people some
people will
be humiliated in cases where they
probably shouldn't because they they
take things too sensitively and and so
there's a there's a balance here you
know
if you want people's lives to improve
you got to be open and honest with them
but you don't have to be a jerk about it
you know
um he also says that the wise person can
get angry and we'll even sometimes
punish people but whenever they're
punishing somebody they're not going to
take enjoyment in it like most other
people do
you know most other people are saying no
i've got you sob you know the wise
person is not going to do that they're
going to feel bad in punishing
and he compares it to drinking wormwood
or absinthe you know which is supposed
to be very bitter it uses the medicine
back at that time or surgery
surgery back then was not what surgery
is now
uh surgery was a last resort you know it
wasn't something that could possibly be
in you know outpatient yeah there's no
occasion surgery at that time so you
know he's comparing anger to that
um
he also says that the errors of the
other person should be taken up in in
sympathy you know that you can you can
say
like you're saying you know i could say
to some of these students which i don't
usually do
i've been where you are i do that with
some students um
i understand what you're going through
you know that's that's showing sympathy
or like you're talking about compassion
um the opposite of that would be um
either harshness or the other thing you
talked about ridicule
oh you're so stupid you know that that's
a mean thing to do to students right
and it's not going to work
um
so he says that anger is you know
naturally human beings and it's going to
have to be dealt with at certain times
there are some cases where we should get
angry
where that's the the right thing for us
to do it's always you know to some
degree a reflection of our vulnerability
to each other
but there's lots of ways in which anger
can go wrong so it is really a middle
position between the aristotelians who
aren't glorifying anger but are they do
have a lot more scope for legitimate
anger and the stoics are saying never
never ever ever get angry um that's
that's what that's what we've got for
the epicurean position
um
it's too bad we don't have the rest of
his his text on anger i wish i really
wish we did
because there might be some really
interesting stuff in there but
um so now let's look you know we have
some time for um
open questions or yeah
um
about the idea that death kind of
negates a focus on the future
okay
um
what about
the focus on the past in other words if
you're uh continually thinking about
um
like maybe looking back to uh your great
ancestors or something like that and
giving yourself uh errors
yeah or just pleasure from the fact that
you're an important person but i mean
really
a big a big past i'm not just talking
about feeling good about yesterday but
yeah
and making that a big part of your life
what how does that relate to the not
looking ahead
well i mean epicurus should probably see
that kind of pleasure
and desire as one that's likely to lead
to
problems unless you're doing it in such
a way that it's not like depending on
other people
in some way treating you
you know according to what your ancestry
you think deserves or stuff like that
lead to some kind of arrogance
it could and if it does then that's
liable to
make you feel pain as a result when
other people don't treat you like you're
somebody special you know but if but if
you were just like
on your own
and you
spent time thinking about pleasant
topics
like your illustrious ancestors and how
cool they were
and and you didn't like it didn't cause
you any trouble i think you would be
okay with that you know
i think it's pretty rare that people do
that did they but was there much like
focus on history or was it more of a
living in the
moment
um
i wouldn't say it was really either
living in the moment would be what like
the hedonists who really focus on the
body would advocate you know
um epicurus is interested in
the space of the life
he didn't seem particularly interested
in you know like the grand sweep of
history because
you're going to die pretty soon
relatively speaking to the grand sweep
of history and it's not going to matter
that much to you um
but what about your
contribution in other words
yes or even the concept of you know
planting an acorn so your children have
an oak tree that's like i pointed out
that's that's where some of the people
were saying you seem to be a little
inconsistent epicurus i mean you've got
this last will and testament that you
know provides for all these people who
are supposed to be taking care of which
slaves are supposed to be freed who's
going to do what in the garden you know
what do you care you're going to be dead
you know
um
so i don't know i i don't have a good
answer for that there i think there is
an inconsistency there well i don't i'm
good i just wanted to finish it
okay
yeah no go ahead
i that the fact about planting a tree or
you want to leave something even if you
feel there's nothing out there you know
once you're gone you're gone you're just
out in the universe
it's
it's a process
that helps
human beings or any
animals because even elephants go go and
and visit their their dead but it's a
process that
like when i think of those things or i'm
preparing my gravestone whatever i say
to myself well i don't know if it's
going to be there if anybody's going to
do what i want it's just that i feel
that i've prepared it and if it's not
there there could be an earthquake
everything goes down right i mean even
with some of those floods they found a
coffin flowing somewhere out in one of
the states you know
so it's just makes that ending i
understand that i'm asking him about in
relation to the epicureans and how they
think that was
is
my
passage in the vatican sayings where he
says something along the lines of um
you know
you should try to leave things better
than you found them
you know
um
and i suppose you could say that if
you're doing that
you're receiving a kind of pleasure
about
it's a mental pleasure about thinking
how
you've you know made things better
um
yeah i i guess you know leaving leaving
things in good order i mean epicurus did
did do the last will and testament and
he seemed to have cared about how the
garden which is his legacy was going to
continue he even like you know provided
for them to celebrate his birthday which
you know did he have children did you
say no he didn't
family
no the the people in the garden were
like his family you know friendship for
epicureans
was was held in such high
respects it's really seen as
he says
prudence or or practical wisdom
is a mortal good friendship is an
immortal good
so there you've got somebody
who's who's who thinks that we're all
mortal
and
who thinks we're all going to die sooner
or later but he says that friendship
isn't immortal but i don't really know
what to make of that myself so i think
that's his answer
to people who say you're being what is
it you said
there's a discrepancy i don't think
that's a discrepancy because he's
talking about if friendship is an
immortal good yeah
then that's what he's doing he's he's
leaving
that you know for them to take on here's
why it seems kind of strange to say that
so the in a friendship the components of
the friendship are the friends
every one of them is mortal
all right so how can the friendship be
immortal when the people who compose the
friendship are all
we're all going to the same place we're
going out into the universe
you know
i mean our atoms are being uh scattered
into the universe
um
but there's no like you know greg sadler
that's going to continue on in the
universe maybe you know virtually in
youtube
yeah well we don't know
but we don't have anything yeah well
i think consistent with what you've
expressed about epicurean beliefs
if you
do something that will help people after
you're dead
you are providing for yourself some
anticipation
of
things that will make you have pleasure
while you're still living yeah if i know
that if i leave a million dollars to you
it will make you happier i feel good
about the thought of it oh i will
a lot of what you described as epicurean
beliefs
are um could be interpreted as
rationalized
principles of morality yeah it's it
really places
a strong emphasis on prudence yeah you
know yeah you can't be a good epicurean
without living in a prudent way um but i
like copper diem you know yeah okay well
the sun chimes
yeah
my point
what
this is a bizarre kind of thinking okay
let's see what's happening today with
all the aggression like isis and all
these young people really being
recruited all this hatred coming out and
everything and then in literature we get
someone like patterson who throws out
that the animals are going to take over
okay this is a weird kind of explanation
of
resolving the anger in the world
are the animals going to be any better
than the humans
oh i don't know the the the patterson
no he writes the appear
he writes all these crazy books um and
uh
i murdered alex patterson
yeah that's in his name he's not
throwing out the animals they're gonna
take over yeah and i'm saying yeah there
is a lot of hatred in this world there's
a lot of ways in which the world is
going direction they're recruiting young
people what's gonna happen in this world
well the animals have gotten angry at
the humans and so they're going to take
over and then i go bizarre in this and i
say now the animal's going to be any
better than the humans are they going to
fight within themselves
well i mean we have a few um that's a
new direction we have a few literary
things like that we think about orwell's
animal farm all the animals are equal
except some are more equal you know
sooner or later but it's because they
behave like human beings and by the end
the pigs are almost human beings they're
walking well
i could see it i mean they just recently
took a video of um i forget what country
it was but
this the elephant the elephant was
passing the road and there was cars on
each side and the baby elephant just
decided it didn't want to walk so it
like lay down
and
they were amazed everybody stopped in
their cars and they took the video and
the other elephants were coming and they
were pushing on the baby elephant to get
up and you watched this whole process of
helping the mother with her elephant
i don't know if we're that good and they
got this baby elephant up and they
passed they passed by and it was just
wonderful i watched it on video yeah it
was really interesting is there marvin
in here yes your wife is on the phone
she said it's an emergency
i don't know what you think
i mean
a lot of the philosophy
is sort of negated by uh science and uh
you know some of the advances that we
made after all it was to try to
acquire knowledge about stuff that we
don't know
yeah but
it's interesting about anger because
psychiatry and psychology uh
is not much bad really yeah it's quite
uh it's still relevant today and it's
still uh
uh
you know i have a degree in psychology
the ancient philosophers were really
good observers of human behavior they're
physical theories yeah i mean
totally you know you can't get anything
out of those now right anger is not a
boiling of blood near the heart
too much hot stuff in our system you
know but yeah i mean they
i think myself that
if we put together
um plato
and we're gonna look at plutarch next
time um as a platoonist aristotle the
stoics
epicurus
and a few other later thinkers like
thomas aquinas
we have insights into the workings of
the emotions rationality and
particularly anger
that
much of the psychological theory can't
even come close to they've they've so
they've treated anger so reductively
um
even people that you know that are very
interesting like freud anger ends up
just being aggression you know
how do we conceptualize that so by going
back to these ancient philosophers we at
least get models i think that that are
useful for thinking about how we we
might you know get ourselves back on
track and understand why we're getting
fights with people but we have to start
really looking at you know there's a lot
that they're discovering with the
science of the brain
sure
yes
yes and no i mean
they still have a long way to go
we know nothing about humans actually
the way we why we think the way but
they're looking at the what is it the
hypothalamus
and yeah but that's just like big global
stuff no no but they're saying that
people who have
empathy
where in the brain it is associated that
some
some people have a bigger hypothalamus
who have yeah i mean that's sort of
ideal i mean
a lot of
yeah that's what i'm saying so we
physically have these different the way
those studies are reported
is usually like this is the way it is
the way the studies are actually
you know documented by the people
carrying them out is yeah we've noticed
this correlation and it might be this
way
and the i mean this the actual science
is very hazy but the thing is the
reporting of it is the where it's like
yeah we're making definite problems i'm
not saying that's done deal yeah i'm
just saying that it it could very well i
mean because we are not all the same
true not just because of you know i mean
there are reasons we we behave
differently not just because of our our
environment but because of our you know
i believe in nature and nurture and
so we can't just have one specific list
of how we do things one of the things
that you're going to find in all these
philosophical things
is there's nature there's nurture and
what science always leaves out because
it's much diff much more difficult to
conceptualize and manage
our choice human freedom and what we do
with nurture and nature and we do have
the freedom if we take on something like
this am i going to be an angry person or
am i going to work on my anger that's
not totally dictated by my genetics
that's not totally dictated by my
environment
at some point i have to make that my own
project
and science cannot quantify that in any
way science is unable to explain where
that decision actually takes place they
can tell you all sorts of stuff about
the about the nurture and the nature but
they can't get at that distance this is
so the controversy on free will
there is still a controversy whether we
completely have freedom here's yeah
here's here's the thing to say about
that first the people involved in the
controversy don't even agree about what
what counts as free will so a lot of
times they're talking past each other
second
it doesn't matter that there's a
controversy because when we're if we're
doing science
right then we need to have consensus
across the board replicability and stuff
like that we're doing philosophy
that's not demanding so we don't need to
have everybody convinced
even you know people who want to say no
there's no free will we don't have them
convinced in order for us to say look i
observe free will
you know
i don't care myself what sam harris
thinks
but satra believed that well if you're
living free will yeah he said that if
you're if you said okay go to war or you
get killed well that's your choice then
get killed if you don't want to go to
war i don't consider that
very much well like well that is free
will oh that's
that's a that's a classic issue that's
been dealt with by aristotle by anselm
you're you're you're making you're sort
of blurring two things together
there's the freedom of choice which
exists and then there's like the freedom
to define your entire situation those
are not the same thing but you have a
natural all human beings all animals
have a natural yes they think for
survival so if you want to survive and
we can choose to go again because we
have free will i don't
do that yeah um the emphasis on of the
epicureans
to me maybe a little more than some of
the other philosophers we've talked
about seems to be
that you this is a practice
and you practice it and so you go back
to the practice as your life goes well
that's that's there are the
aristotelians too and that's there in
the stoics they all
saw philosophy as a way of life
so um
if you want to
if you want to quit being as angry i'm
not going to say quit being angry right
because
we're probably always going to be angry
you want to have better control of your
anger
they all think that you got to do
something
uh over and over again in order to
change it they don't always agree on
how far it's supposed to go
or what techniques you would use but
even the epicureans didn't you know like
with philadelphus
some of the epicureans were saying
um
look it doesn't do any good to try to
intervene when a person is angry and
philodemus is saying that's the best
time to do it you know
um
interestingly
on that philodemus would be lined up
with the aristotelians
and the other epicureans would be lined
up more with the stoics who tend to
think that look once once you've given
into anger too late it's it's off and
running and doing what it does and maybe
you can clean up after after you've you
know got your brain back you know
um
so
yeah i mean they all have an emphasis on
practice they'll be the same thing with
plutarch when we look at him next time
he's giving advice about what to do with
your anger how to how to how to be less
angry from a platonic perspective
um
yeah
go ahead what what's
what i've been pondering again i was
very struck in the discussion that we
had after your last talk
about the story
yes and the thing about it um i found
myself very much feeling like a stoic
although i found in the group people
really want to tell everybody else
exactly what to do and think um it was
pretty common
but i thought at the time that
oh
it's not necessarily wrong to keep your
own comfort and i'm struck with our
discussion here
today that
we are not involved in a discussion of
how we fix the whole rest of the world
or tell our best friend what they're
doing wrong
nearly as much as we were last week
last month with the stoics yeah
i mean the stomachs themselves didn't
worry about fixing the whole world
because they thought that the whole
world was gonna more or less stay
screwed up and they could like control
this little bit you know
uh
i don't know maybe we got it out of
ourselves you can always control your
own world your own little space a little
local your own little space you live it
the way you whether you want to be
stoked or is the truth
or whatever
i've i've been part of some of these
prior discussions i'm sorry to say but
it strikes me just from uh you know this
last hour especially that the ancient
philosophers really uh had it pretty
easy because they didn't have to
confront questions
uh for instance about global warming
about the great ethical issues that
we're facing now they the world was a
fine and infinite place to them that
yeah human numbers could expand
uh species weren't vanishing the earth
wasn't the environmental systems weren't
collapsing so i find that you know from
the standpoint of not just anger but
just yeah in general the ancient
philosophers were
pretty easy you know that's sort of my
impression i wouldn't say easily because
they're because most of the problems of
the human condition are present then we
have some new problems certainly
but um i mean they were dealing with
uh
some things that that we don't find to
be quite as big of a problem like the
fact that
um when you went to war most of the
casualties were due to infection and
disease and wars were constantly
happening then and
you know i mean i think there's there's
a trade-off there and the other thing we
could think about is
do they
you know
you're right they they weren't really
thinking about environmental concerns or
stuff like that
could they think about that today using
their
their framework um some of them yes and
i think some of them know you know
um
that would be one of those things where
you want to look at what
people who identify themselves with
these particular schools today what they
have to say about it
like i know the neo-stoics um they talk
about environmental concerns but they're
they're not just using you know the
texts that they have they got to do some
extrapolation and
um
i don't know about epicureans and
because i don't know many
neo-epicureans
you know
yeah
anger and it's it's interesting i mean
the uh detail
uh
uh he specifically points out
uh
it's not good to be angry with the
slaves the children yeah
it's amazing the level of abuse the
the
yeah our males dominate the uh
uh
society and their ranking uh
so it's very germane in today's world i
mean
yeah yes you're right it's it's it's
horrible i mean i
i i'm not very young but my first job
was working on wall street doing
investment research believe me
that is
talk about power and
press oh everything
it's
seared my soul
yeah i think anytime there's a power
differential
some people are going to be more
vulnerable so philadelphia you know they
didn't they didn't have any sort of
conception of like race back then right
but um
if if philadelphus were here in our
society race would be an issue
well slavery might have been a little
bit comparable yeah yeah
well you know
yeah and you know in
in our society it was rather unique in
that slavery was effectively based on on
race we actually shifted from a
something very much like slavery
indentured servitude which had no racial
connections to um
racial based slavery
um
and then you know had to deal with still
dealing with the legacy of that
um
but you know yeah any sort of power
differential philadelus would say
there's a vulnerability there where the
people who are on top get to be angry
and
it's very easy for them to like be
abusive
and then the people on the bottom have
to suck it up you know they don't get to
be angry even though they have more
cause to be angry
yeah if you ignore that kind of thing in
in in any age in any era
you you big problems just
just fester yeah and that's what we're
seeing
that's really what we're saying
it it it was it was going to happen
sooner or later and it and it could
happen even here in our united states